The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So let's see if you
can figure out this next error.
Oh, nice.
Looks like 100% are
getting it right so far.
So we have L is equal to 3 for
i in range length L print i.
And this is the error message
telling me the file, the line
number, and the actual
line that was wrong
and then a description
of the error type error.
OK?
And everyone's getting
it right, which
is, what's the problem here?
We're not allowed to call
length on an integer.
OK?
If you go through
the other choices,
you'll see that those
you can actually do.
And you can even test
those out yourself
before you settle
on the right answer.